hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
are prototyping a more sustainable way
of living not sure how it's going to go
but let's see
and in the previous video you could see
us cleaning up a lot of things from the
kitchen to the swamp to the lake and
there's one thing we never really dared
to clean because it was a bit big
yeah today we are cleaning the workspace
and because it's so big we need quite a
lot of people so these are the people
that are with us this is the workspace
behind us that we have to clean so we
are about to start
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so yeah as you can see the place is
quite rough the roof collapsed a few
years ago in a big forest fire and so
there are now rooftops scattered all
over the floor
and it's also just really overgrown
thorns everywhere around it outside
but also grown inside which makes it
very hard to access this place
we actually don't really have a clue
what the building looks like
and if we zoom out we have the workspace
here the kitchen we cleaned before here
and the base camp we set up right there
so up until now the best visual we got
from this building is with a drone
so we're very curious to find out what's
underneath this pile of thorns
so time to get started and we really
want to clean it now because it's not
often we have many people to help on the
land
but there's one downside it's raining
a lot
so first a good breakfast and see how
everyone is feeling
[Applause]
the water
[Applause]
are you happy rita with the ring
very happy
i love it
what do you think about the rain i love
it
although there's some water coming in my
van at the moment
what do you think about the ring yeah
no thinking about the rain how do you
feel about the rain guys
very natural
it's like my elements
[Music]
[Music]
okay
so we have a plan
and the strategy is that we start from
the outside cutting with the bush cutter
in front
all the silvers and the brambles
around a bit closer to the building we
have some small scissors and smaller
tools to cut the brambles and small
bushes which are around and behind there
is someone with a chainsaw chopping down
the trees which are very close to the
building
once this is done we go to the inside of
the building and we tidy up the rest
[Music]
[Music]
uh
i should also advise a long sleeves cat
yeah i just had long sleeves but the
things were grabbing on them so much
so grab your skin yeah i better grab my
screen
[Music]
so here we are at the back of the
workspace and as you can see there's a
lot of trees falling on the structure a
lot of thorns a lot of bushes and
basically we want to clear out
all the material that's close to the
workspace that way we can have a better
idea about what's going on
that way we can take measurements
and you want to come back here you can
see a little bit
we're trying to clear out a space here
so we can really walk in here
but really comes up right to the
workspace
let's chop some bushes
[Music]
[Music]
so we're currently making the best use
of all our
bas and masters and phds
really putting them to use
currently i'm getting rid of all the
horns
so that we can at least move around put
them inside for now what's kind of
interesting is that it's a big
mass of roots
so it's like one big mass that you can
almost
take up
and
quite amazing the web that is generated
under the ground
but it's also
well heavy as you can tell
lots of work lots of swag
and much more to go so you're gonna go
here continue
yeah nexus i guess that that black hole
is gonna be the next one to be tackled
[Music]
so now jan will sort of lower all this
mess cut with a brush cutter like you
know go through the big messy part
sort of loading a bit however there's
loads of like bricks and cement and
tiles in there which can be
problematic with a brush cutter because
they can spark and can be also dangerous
for yarn so we're going to lower the
whole thing and then we're going to go
in with a shovel and i guess put it all
inside yeah sounds like a plant
power of technology
[Music]
bye
how's it going guys
[ __ ] is good
so we found
bar wire again on the land this seems to
be surrounding the whole land and we
find that every time we do a cleaning
it grows it's very annoying because it
grows like between the silvers or the
brumbles and when we try to cut it with
a bush cutter the thing gets all around
the machine and it kind of gets really
stuck rather dangerous and annoying
and more annoying part is to try to take
it out because it's just one ball
of
stuff spiky stuff yeah
so yeah there's still way more brush
cutting work to do so we could also use
a gas powered brush cutter and it's kind
of fun actually to test the difference
between both
that's into this yeah not really
it's more of a guess split the eyeballs
so while they're working here we also
made some progress on the back side to
clear out the space
this is the back side of the workspace
and there was a lot of trees and bushes
and now we are slowly working our way
our way towards to
the end of the wall this is like halfway
now
so yeah
a lot of cutting and making the wood in
a size that we can actually then
transport it to somewhere else or
make something with it
yeah so we still have to go here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
hey cutting
all these trees we found
a treasure in the camp so this old
motorbike i guess or it looks like a
motorbike at least when like you see
trees started to grow even in the middle
of the wheel
some good old spring
probably not so springy anymore
broken wheel
it will have quite some space to do like
an electric motorbike or something like
that
oh yes
do i look cool
you think it's broken no i think i think
it might still work
i think i just i just missed the key
that's all everything else looks like
in a good state wow that looks fine
look it's it's a wolf like a fire wolf
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so we've been clearing up this
garage or whatever whatever it is we
found
a barrel
full of water i guess
some plastic which survived
and some other plastic stuff and also a
hole
which is part of this bigger kind of lid
here
and we can see some pipes in there so it
might have been a septic tank or
something like that do you see it
youtube
it's right
there yes
[Applause]
and maybe a sauce
look we can even see it
i don't know what that is
ketchup
i think we have to bend that up
okay
cooking anyway
[Applause]
[Music]
this one is too big this one
[Applause]
is it is it like a well
no i think just
all right so finally the whole outside
is ready and the last part we need to do
is clean the inside of the building
at first we cut all the bushes just down
and it's actually cool to see what's
underneath
and here there are also some small holes
and a big one in the middle not sure
and after chopping down all the bushes
we remove the roots
and cleaning roots and bushes here is
somewhat easier it's kind of satisfying
because they grow on top of the stones
so you can almost drag them out like a
carpet
it's quite nice to do
[Music]
ah
[Music]
so here we have it the cleaned up
workspace
it's actually quite different than
expected it's an old cow shot but we
didn't know it was this big and it had
all these different rooms and heights in
the floor
and even when zooming out you see it's
quite a big structure on the land
that's cool
[Music]
but let me show you a tour of what it
looks like down there
so this is the front part of the
building is huge now we can see all the
size of the place
and now i can show you around a bit more
so first thing we've done was
try to see the worst piece so we clear
all around
we are all just freeze with mimosa
spawns around
so from here we have a nice view now
this is the worst part of all the 316
years
so this is the other time you can just
see now it's a clean wall it was before
full of thorns so we found a similar
place of what we found in the kitchen
where we previously cleaned where a
place where probably the animals used to
drink some water we found that there's
cement down here
so there are some hollow parts under
here we don't know why
treasure
maybe see this is probably the area
where the cow [ __ ] got done
and this probably the best part i think
is what i used to milk the cows but
imagine this thing filled with hot water
and in all the squares you have some
candles so you have a nice
steamy sauna swimming pool going on here
a lot of potential we clean this part so
now it's everything but we didn't clean
this part because this
roof looks a bit scary so it's a bit
dangerous
we will think about it in the future but
for now it's going to stay like this
finally here you can see all the storms
that we took out to mimosa trees that
were around
all right yes so here we have our
cleaned up workspace
and the main reason to do this was
actually to understand even the
structure on the land because we could
never access it and now we can go in
take measurements but also really see
what is the condition of the building
can we reuse it do we need to renovate
it or take down the whole thing we're
not sure yet we're going to look into
that now
and one of the questions that also
popped up actually is that we always
call this thing the workspace we saw
this as this is going to be a workspace
but being here and seeing the place in
the different rooms it has we thought it
would also be a cool community place a
place where you can gather where you can
chill or you can do meetings
so we're not sure actually what this is
going to be like if you have suggestions
make sure to leave them in the comments
but yeah all this planning and next
steps we're gonna do later and for now i
think we're gonna take a little rest
thank you guys for watching if you like
what we do make sure to visit
support.projectcom.com to see how you
can help out
have a good day and see you in the next
update